مختلف وسائل الاعلام ومن حول العالم اليوم
بتابع مجريات قمه مجموعه العشرين المناقده
في بالي بسبب ما صحه وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سرجا لابروف كان لها نصيب كبير من
العناوين اليوم فبعد وصوله الى جزيره بالي
يتناقلت وسائل الاعلام انباء عن نقل
لافروف للمستشفى بسبب عرض صحي في القلب
وقيل ايضا انه اجرب فحوصات طبيه غادر
المستشفى من بعدها هذه الانباء اكدتها
مصادر صحيه اندونيسيه اندونيسيه واحنا
بنحكي هون يعني وسائل الاعلام مرموقه يعني
اللي نقل الخبر هي وكاله السوشيه ومصادرهم
كانوا اربع مسؤولين طبيين اندونيسيين من
بينهم مدير اداره الخدمات الصحيه في وزاره
الصحه الاردنيه
لاجتماعات القمه
ونتابع طبعا شرائط الاخبار او هي قالت انه
ونحن جالسين يعني عم نتابع شرعيه الاخبار
وما عم بنصدق عيوننا من كم تزييف الانباء
وما اكتفت حتى بالمنشور فقط لكن نزلت كمان
فيديو للابراف لتثبت انه صحته عال العال
ووجه رساله للاعلام الغربي كمان
همم
طبعا اللي بيشوف الفيديو بيقول انه يعني
خلاص افهم الناس وخصوصا معارضين روسيا
واعدائها بالصوت والصوره وقال لهم ووصل
لهم الفكره انه هو فل الفل وصحته على
العالم بس الناس تركت صحته وموضوع القلب
والمستشفى وانتبهت لموضوع ثاني تماما ففي
الفيديو في الفيديو ومثل ما شايفين امامكم
الان لاحظ الناس تلفون على الطاوله وساعه
في يدها برافو قالوا انه هذول اطول واتش
وايفون يعني منتجات امريكيه يعني قايمه
القيامه ما بين روسيا وما بين امريكا
وعقوبه والف قصه ولافراف بيستعمل منتجات
امريكيه معقول هذا الكلام
اجى عليه رد فلافل الصحفي انه الساعه كانت
كمان انه التليفون يكون ايفون وقالت انه
التليفون مش ايفون ابدا لكن الشغل الوحيد
اللي ما حضرت عليها ولا لحظه
اذا المحبين الفاشل هي التيشرت اللي كان
لابسها لابروف واللي هي من ماركت جون
ميشيل باسكال وهاي بالمناسبه او هذا مصمم
امريكي
[موسيقى]